Hey, so this next story is not the biggest
story, but I do like something that Nancy
Pelosi is doing because it's fighting Donald
Trump with his own tactics in a way that's
not immoral.
Now, I've pointed out many times before, we
are trying to fight the immorality of the
right.
We are trying to fight the destructive impulses
of the right.
We don't want to fight those destructive,
immoral impulses by being destructive and
immoral ourselves.
So on a lot of policy based things, I've made
it very clear we should not stoop to their
level.
We don't be the country doesn't benefit in
the long run from the left to becoming just
as destructive and immoral as the right merely
to justify replacing the right.
However, there are some optics elements where
I actually think it's okay to adopt some of
the strategies of Trump.
And one of these is Nancy Pelosi starting
to refer to the Corona virus as the Trump
virus.
Now, a few weeks ago, I jokingly tweeted,
we should really call it Trump Kobie 20.
And some people like that.
Some people didn't.
But really, the idea is we have to brand Trump
with the failure.
We have to brand the failure with Donald Trump's
name.
And Nancy Pelosi is doing it.
This doesn't mean Nancy Pelosi is a progressive.
This doesn't mean anything other than Nancy
Pelosi is using one of Trump's more innocuous
techniques against Trump.
And I know there are people who are going
to flippantly say, okay, Nancy, you know,
Trump virus is clever.
But what about getting people relief money?
I agree.
Right.
I'm not saying that this is a replacement
or an excuse for anything, but I do think
that fighting Trump's, you know, Cung flu
stuff with some of his own medicine is interesting
nonetheless.
So here's Nancy Pelosi on CNN.
It is a pandemic that has gotten worse before.
It will get better because it his an action
and in fact, clearly it is the Trump virus.
Well, what do you mean when you say the Trump
virus tried virus it?
If he had said months ago, let's wear masks,
let's not let's socially dist. instead of
having rallies and political whatever they
were, then more people would have followed
his lead.
Is the president of the United States, instead
of being a bad example, making it like a manhood
thing, not to wear a mask?
Certainly.
That was weird because a briefing on the Corona
virus should be about science.
And that is something the president has ignored.
It should be about governance.
And now he's finally embracing, saying, OK,
it's OK to wear a mask.
So I think a good deal of what we have suffered
clearly that Trump virus.
Now, I know that even within our audience,
there is a split on this type of thing.
What's the point of these superficial things
when Nancy Pelosi has been part of the failure
to get substantive financial relief to all
America?
Things people are writing to me, you know,
this is Crum's when we need a main course
Trump virus.
Woo!
OK, what about money for people who need it?
I agree with you.
But to restate, this is not a replacement
or an alternative to anything that should
have been done and should be done and could
be done.
Failures remain failures, whether they're
the Democratic Party or Trump or the Republican
Party or whoever.
But the attempt to brand Trump with the excess
destruction of this pandemic is not stupid.
It's the number one issue right now for voters
in the 2020 election.
More people than necessary have died because
of this administration's mishandling of the
corona virus.
So if it's the most important issue to voters
and according to a recent poll, it is.
And Trump has failed on it.
And it's one of the biggest drags on Donald
Trump's approval.
And we all understand that for the sake of
saving lives, Trump must be removed in November.
This is an opportunity that is not the left
becoming destructive and stooping to the level
of the right in a substantive way.
This is optics, and I think it's an opportunity
to hit Trump with it.
Period.
And it should be done.
It's no major thing, but it's a dig and it
could trigger Trump again to react in an unhinged
way.
Doubling the damage.
Now, you might remember Trump also likes to
call Corona virus the plague.
The term Trump plague is interesting to me
because it encompasses not just the virus
being the Trump plague, but this administration
being a plague.
And beyond that, from failing on the Trump
virus caused the Trump recession.
He must be voted out before we have a Trump
war.
There is a cohesive nature to it that I don't
think should be ignored.
Now, by the way, instead of starting a war
with another country.
Trump is starting a conflict domestically
between federal and local law enforcement
with these deployments of paramilitaries to
cities like Portland, Oregon.
I talked to you earlier in the show about
Donald Trump's announcement yesterday that
he's going to be deploying them to Chicago.
This is another version of starting an armed
conflict, but this one is within our borders
instead of beyond them, which is often a tool
that presidents look to use as they are approaching
a possible reelection.
So bottom line, political name calling is
indeed childish.
You are not wrong.
But when it comes to this and this kind of
final sprint to try to remove Donald Trump,
Democrats playing the games Trump plays when
they don't lead to death and destruction.
I'm okay with.
But if we don't vote, it's all B.S.
It's just it's just wasting time.
We have to vote in November earlier.
If you have absentee ballot access, if you
have early voting access.
If we don't, this is all a waste of time.
I hate wasting my time.
I like making things happen.
I'm a pragmatist.
Sometimes people in the audience get mad at
me.
They say you're being too pragmatic.
Well, listen, with all of this stuff, what
matters is removing Trump in November and.
Oh, and by the way, Magga flu also a reasonable
alternative for me to the Trump virus.
I'm really fine with whatever as long as it
points to helping us remove this guy as soon
as possible, which is about three months and
a week
from now.